It's time to begin adding the methods
that actually save changes that
the user makes.
Remember that up until this point
we could change the text of our
default note.
But that whenever the app relaunched,
the same text for
that note would appear and any changes
added by the user would be lost.
We can persist the user's changes to
the note by adding just a few lines.
Let's take another look at
our core data stack struct.
If we scroll down to the bottom we can
see that we have this extension here
that already contains what looks to
be a save function, save context.
If context.hasChanges try context.save.
So, it looks at this is a wrapper
function for this context.save function.
So what is this .save function?
It looks like it's a function of an
estimated object context and it attempts
to commit unsaved changes to registered
objects to the receiver's parent store.
Okay so perfect.
It looks like all we need to do is
call this save contexts function for
instance of core data stack when
we want to save or changes.
But I guess the question is then where
and when do we want to call this.
Several things happen when the save
function is called on context.
All properties and
relationships are validated.
All new and
modified objects are saved to disk, and
all deleted objects
are removed from the database.
These three steps, depending on
how much data we're dealing with,
could actually take a human
perceivable amount of time.
Because of this,
it's really important to think about and
carefully choose when
to call this function.
If we call it after every
change the user makes,
the app will become sluggish and
possibly timeout.
But if we call it too seldomly, we
risk the user potentially losing data.
So when is the right time to save?
Let's look through some of the methods
in our app delegate that represent
the different states of
the app's life cycle and
see if maybe one of those methods is
a good place to save the app's state.